i'll get an award for
the best outer space movie
[Music]
what do you think the movie's about the
movie is about a girl
named fave and she's trying to save
chonga's life
how does she build a rocket to the moon
she takes a bunch of stuff people don't
need anymore and she builds a rocket
ship
the moon is like really far away from
earth like it's really really far away
it would probably take 15 hours
probably more than 2 000 minutes that'd
be a long time
yeah i would love to know what your
favorite scene was
when she gets to go to the moon they had
a big dance party
marlo do you have a favorite song i like
the one when they're making the moon
cakes
stuff would you recommend this
to your friends i would recommend this
movie to my friends
close to my friends like outer space and
trying to do stuff that they can do
they say i can't do this but i'm gonna
try
marlo do you know what an oscar is
but actually i don't oscar
is an award that they give for movies
i'm okay i think this movie deserves an
oscar
it teaches people that they could do
things even though they don't know they
can't
why did you think of making the movie
the moon goddess
she's very famous in china we thought
it would be really fun to share her
story with kids all around the world
do you think feike really went to the
moon and came back
i don't think fei fe was dreaming i
think it actually happened
the ending made me feel happy thank you
marlo thank you marlo
it's so nice to meet you bye
you